mr. sides of the life my name is Becky
I'm Ramsey hi I'm Jelena
hi I'm Rachel and we're playing never
have I ever law school edition never
have I ever cheated on a test in law
school I have not I've thought about it
it's impossible during those 2 to 4 hour
exams you have at least three people
walking around looking so it's not and
they wait for you outside of the
bathroom until yeah I'm like a real gun
yeah I gotta leave by the time I got to
law school I was like I can miss knives
I can do Padova's yeah so Sam I did
cheat on an exam once in junior high
Oh high school in hell never have I ever
thought about or actually rage quit law
school I don't think I not rage credit
it's been like no very meditative yeah I
feel like I've thought yeah what do i do
not know rage but no I have been so
angry that I have considered walking out
of law school and had it not cost so
much money I might have I did too but
then I realized that I didn't have
scholarships so I needed to be there
yeah yeah normal that's normal
never have I ever come to school under
the influence that is that is a big now
our school wise a kind of conservative
Christian dry campus you wouldn't show
up to law school under the influence and
certainly not certainly not at the
school that we went to does bar prep
count drinks are cheaper during the week
as a law student you're a law student
you are broke so you go out took
advantage of those happy hours oh my God
my first hangover
during bar prep and came and still kinda
drunk throwing up on the basement in the
bathroom of the basement of a Korean
church never have I ever dated another
lawyer person in law all my boyfriend's
I thought I would ever do because around
them all the time yeah it kind of comes
incestuous I think it resulted in like
more arguments of animals yeah think
about they take different yaks on
whatever say amendment what's your
definition of dated I have had relations
with a lawyer who did go to law school
at the same time as us okay more than
one now that well never hurt nobody
yeah and then when it's all done
exercise of the like never have I ever
fallen asleep in class not during law
school
I know sometimes those professors get up
there and just like today we're going to
talk about a silver procedure in this
lake
everything's exciting yeah if you I mean
the thing that scared me was not that's
not an option
your entire grade is that one exam at
the end of the semester so there's no
other like things to hold you love and
it's something okay make up extra credit
like the mo there is none of that
they're like you're gonna take this
class again and they're gonna get put on
academic probation
yeah or usually just ask you to leave
school never have I ever thought I made
the wrong decision about going into law
school I have thought that I made the
wrong decision by going to law school
and some days I still think that I mean
I think I am
until you how you haven't my dad was an
attorney so when I was younger you know
I used to watch him go with this
briefcase and he looked very important
growing up I did like acting a little so
I kind of thought it would be like in
the courtroom yeah you know yeah ladies
and gentlemen of the jury type things so
I think once I made my decision I I
stuck with it
um law school itself is very hard it
involves a lot of Tears
like decision at least once a week yeah
being lawyers very hard it still
involves a lot of Tears so yeah I
definitely sometimes wonder how
different my life would be if I couldn't
go never ever had to pull an all-nighter
are you much every class every class
yeah I used to I was on the new cork
team and I had friends on Law Review in
law journal and so I used to collect
keys to the offices near campus so I
could sleep on on campus I had spent I
would take nights off of law school like
there were nights where I'm like oh you
know I'm just not gonna do the reading
tonight because I need to go out holding
all my different study yeah what I had
those two nights of going out that was
like okay I'm a little behind now maybe
I should like ketchup and much my
judgment I would spend all night reading
and catching up never have I ever
thought I was going to fail after 1l
which is first year I have not after 1l
during after our first semester I went
home to Arizona and I was getting my
hair done and my hair girl found bald
patches from stress they went to the bar
I worked at and asked my old manager if
I could have my job back
in case I failed out but then after
those grades came in and after second
semesters grades came in my GPA was at a
point that I knew it would be more
difficult to fail out than not once you
get through the first year you pretty
much like know how to do law school
after that I was like every time we got
any great back it's on a curve right so
it's a constant competition every time
final sudden gonna be yeah I guess it's
like a worry yeah every time finals and
rolls around
never have I ever gone out drinking with
friends after we all thought we failed
an important exam dance and karaoke
okay something anything to forget about
the misery
I like after an exam okay so your
minimum exam is two hours and they can
be up to four hours straight I was
always so genuinely emotionally and
physically exhausted that even if I
wanted to like I just wanted to go home
and sleep opposite I'm glad we were able
to share our experiences you don't have
to eighth law school to get a job
everyone has their own experience with
law school it's different in every state
it's different for every person it's
different by school and you should never
feel pressured to do with someone else's
way
[Music]
[Music]